herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren so viertel nach dem tag der
schlagzeilen machen nachdem gestern der
historische tag war für olaf scholz
kanzler wurde war heute auch direkt die
erste corona gipfel angesagt dabei
möchten wir gleich direkt sprechen und
die ergebnisse von heute analysieren
meine gäste heute abend sind ritual ist
hans ulrich jörges politikredaktion
neuen züricher zeitung alexander kissler
chefreporter politik peter thiel der den
ganzen tag in gipfel beobachtet hat und
last but not least der chefredakteur der
weltwoche roger köppel und mein name ist
den asik falls sich allein gestellt
haben das konzept ist er einfach jeder
von uns hat etwas mitgebracht was ihn
bewegt schockiert wir wo wir einfach
vielleicht mal debattieren möchte mit
anderen ich habe mir heute überlegt wir
müssen natürlich über den cola gibt für
debattieren und was ist für uns
eigentlich bedeutet aber da ich nehme
mal nicht die expertin bin aber einer
neben mir sitzt gebe ich direkt an
platinen was sind die ergebnisse also
ergebnis erstmal angela merkel hat nicht
mehr da gesessen und es gibt ein im
landtag noch und langweilige reden als
die kanzlerin der hat soul abschaltung
ist jetzt kanzler man muss schon genau
hinhören und man ist markus
strömungsabriss wenn er redet aber man
muss auch so genau hinhören nicht nur
weil er leise spricht sondern auch was
da zwischen den zwischen den zeilen
steht und was da gesagt oder halt nicht
gesagt wird und wir waren ja immer so
halbwegs live dabei wie kriegen
immunsystems nachrichten aus den großen
runden raus und es gab es oft zum zum
schluss zum mindesten und da ging es
nämlich darum ob man vor weihnachten
noch mal eine mpk macht gedachten ja
schon wir sind mit dem ding mal am ende
irgendwann und ich stand ja dann
nächtelang und tage lang immer vor dem
bundeskanzleramt hat man daraus dann
begleitet wird heute mal im warmen und
es könnte sein dass noch eine kriegen
also fasst noch einmal zusammen es kommt
die die impfpflicht für bestimmte
einrichtungen also für alles was krank
überall wohl krank und zu fliegende sind
kommt für alle mitarbeiter die
impfpflicht auch in
behinderteneinrichtungen also jeder der
nicht weglaufen kann vor vor vor
ungeimpften und selber vielleicht nicht
geben werden kann da kommt jetzt die
impfpflicht das ist das eine das andere
ist dass in der nächsten woche zum
ersten mal der expertenrat takt den
urlaub scholz einberufen hat die ampel
hat klingt jetzt ein bisschen
bürokratisch und ex expertenrat ist aus
meiner sicht zumindest ein fortschritt
weil bisher hatten wir über den geheimen
zirkel von frau merkel die sich am
wochenende telefonisch mit irgendwelchen
wissenschaftlern von ihm erfahren habe
wohl auch nicht erfahren dass sie mit
ihnen spricht und sich von ihm beraten
lässt das ist abgelöst und durch ein
transparentes gremium man kann immer
noch darüber streiten wer das ist und
wir werden uns sicherlich auch darüber
streiten aber zumindest gibt es ein
stückchen transparenz und man muss 1
konzentrieren zumindest aus liberaler
sicht ist es ist ein vorteil dass dann
nicht einfach mehr
das ist nicht einfach mehr im dunkeln
irgendwas entschieden wird sondern dass
auch bestimmte sachen wieder
zurückgegeben werden da hin wo sie
hingehören die entscheidung wieder
zurück ins parlament dass die
ermächtigung für die bundesregierung
nicht mehr da sondern dass da
entschieden werden muss wo der ofen
brennt also entweder in den
bundesländern und auch in den
parlamenten aber ansonsten kommt das war
ganz klare ansage es kommt die
impfpflicht also nicht nur die bezogene
wird hier nach dem bundestag abgestimmt
hat nicht den ton etwas verwundert wie
ging es dir oder auch alexander als ihr
dann gehört ja die kommt eigentlich wird
noch abgestimmt ja gott das ist doch
bekannt dass die entscheidungen immer
fallen bevor das parlament sie überhaupt
damit beschäftigt da ist schon alles
beschlossen das kennen wir doch in
deutschland
wird gar nicht manche aber einmal in
zehn jahren auf eine abstimmung aber
hier gibt es offene abstimmungen zur
tour zugelassen werden dass sogar ein
gewisser bestimmt da zusammensitzen
ehrlich gesagt wenn man nichts
mitzuteilen hat sondern auch keine
pressekonferenz machen ich habe hier nur
schlafes bruder gesehen und zwar alle
miteinander einer langweilig als der
andere und so kann man natürlich jedes
interesse an corona politik auch
ersticken die hatten nichts mitzuteilen
und olaf scholz hatte nur einen einzigen
zweck bei der ganzen veranstaltung zu
zeigen dass er da ist und dieses format
was sie heute wieder fortgesetzt haben
das ist das alte merkel format sollte es
eigentlich nicht mehr geben diese mpk
präsidiert vom vom bundeskanzler und
dann sitzen sie alle wieder
nebeneinander und wenn ich herrn müller
aus berlin sehe ich kann gar nicht
fassen dass der erde hat gesagt lasst ja
immer noch dabei ist also es war sein
letztes mal als offen gelegt es
losgehen aber des hofs nicht losgehen es
muss ein bisschen
konzentration ein bisschen was wenn man
macht eine pressekonferenz war mal was
beschlossen hat und teilt es dann mit
aber wenn man nichts beschlossen hat
soll man bitte im hinterzimmer bleiben
und stehen nach hause fahren hat als du
hast mich nur wenn ich das sehe dass
leute sich das antun müssen anzugucken
und dann zogen sie nach einer nachricht
was haben jetzt beschlossen nix haben
sie beschloss aber ich fand es schon
erstaunlich meine es wird eben schon
gesagt wir haben morgen eine abstimmung
haben da wird es höchstwahrscheinlich
eine spezielle impfpflicht geben eine
einrichtungs abhängige impfpflicht für
beschäftigte in kranken und heilberufen
auch für zahnärzte und ärzte allgemein
aber danach wird es kommen wir uns eben
schon gesagt eine allgemeine impfpflicht
tritt vielleicht sogar schon vor dieser
speziell im pflicht im kraft- und herr
wüst der nordrhein westfälische minister
bei sind hat gesagt wir dürfen nichts
liegen lassen an zeit wir müssen tempo
gewinnen bei der beratung eine
allgemeine impfpflicht und das finde ich
schon erschütternd mit welchem tempo man
sich doch an nach wie vor immer
drakonischen einschnitten und die
freiheit gewöhnt gewöhnt und wie gesagt
werden nicht nur eine bedingte im
pflicht ist wird schon eine allgemeine
impfpflicht als alternativlos ausgegeben
ohne hinreichende beratungen darüber das
finde ich schon erschreckend wir wollen
natürlich auch deinen blick aus der
schweiz natürlich haben wir die runde
jede lang behält sich der in dämonische
gewohnheit vor
diesem monument der unauffällig beiden
ist der dämon ich muss sagen das ist ein
ausdruck gewitzt und hans blumenberg den
bedeutenden deutschen philosophen ich
dachte du kennst das oldtimer aber ich
glaube wenn ich hier noch ein bisschen
hier nach deutsche bildungs schätze
heben kann nein der olaf scholz ist ja
wirklich schweren momente
unaufgeregtheit ich finde diese coolness
titel aus der alte finde ich wahnsinnig
und das stimmt ja eigentlich wollte es
nun hat er spielte mehr die nationale
karte dort titel außerdem dass nur die
schweizer sind sehr internationale
werden wir wollen nicht immer auf
unserer nationalität reduziert werden
auch wenn wir uns akzentfreies
hochdeutsch ausdrücken können ja nein
der der schweiz also unaufgeregt und ich
freue mich okay jetzt die fdp noch in
deutschland ist die diese rauchen der
regierung sie haben gesagt es gibt keine
eben einfach stolz auch gesagt mit licht
und das da muss ich aber sagen immer
sind ja alle regierungen etwas am
schwimmen auch in der schweiz dort sogar
ein regierungsmitglied zugegeben man sei
dort ziemlich fakten frei unterwegs von
seiten des bundesrates was ich ja eine
ganz bemerkenswerte aussage finden dass
ihr seht auch bei uns läuft nicht
optimal sind pflicht in der schweiz ein
und sie haben auch kein zweig der schon
ein echter ein es gibt so eine
freiwillige möglichkeit man kann das
anwenden ich bin dagegen ich finde es
einfach absurd dass der staat den leuten
befehlen muss gesund zu bleiben also wir
leben in einer welt in der man uns nicht
mehr zutraut dass wir selber das
kostbarste gut verwalten können nämlich
unsere gesundheit wir sind jetzt
umzingelt von journalisten die uns das
impfen ein predigen wir sind umzingelt
von politiken wir können denen nicht
mehr den kommen nicht mal mehr in dieser
sendung die noch heute keinen richtigen
die keine im fläche gar nichts für auch
nicht sein also ich wäre mir nicht
bekannt und ich finde das einfach fort
der stadt hat doch nicht direkt das
recht uns eine medizinische aufbauen für
mich war heute das aufregendste ehrlich
gesagt und was natürlich überhaupt keine
rolle spielt dass herr lauterbach gesagt
hat zweig zu begrenzen auf die dreimal
geimpften wie viele sind es im moment in
deutschland drei millionen fotos aber
nicht sofort nicht sofort nicht sofort
ging ja auch gar nicht könnten von 80
millionen nach 3 millionen beleidigen
aber wenn man jetzt soweit ist gerade
die leute zu überzeugen dass es sich
erste mal und es weiter mal eben dann
schon zu sagen ihr müsst euch drei mal
impfen lassen wenn überhaupt noch am
leben teilnehmen darin ist das nicht
ehrlich ist vorher ein und zu sein mai
musste schließen sollen haben letzten
menschen hut nehmen ich würde unter
holen dafür deutlich wer die rovers
haben immer ein bisschen generell
behauptung wenn sowas kommt das
sicherlich nicht in der koalition
abgestimmt war ganz sicher nicht werde
die fdp nicht mitgemacht die mussten
sich gleich greifen und sagen das will
ich wollen wir nicht normal erleben dass
ich wieder an
meine behauptung dass wichtig ganz kurz
er klarstellen ich habe nämlich mal
verglichen daneben wirken das meiste war
eine idee haben und noch scharf ist dass
die nebenwirkungen sind uns machine
masern und corona vergleicht man gaming
pflicht und die nebenwirkungen von der
krone impfungen sind wesentlich höher
diese alle zusammen die cd fälle als bei
der basis stimmt denn nach der verlegung
oder von oben oder von erkrankungen also
die muss dann schon korrekt bleiben es
gibt niemand
darf ich meine
in dieser runde hinein wer für wen
stellen eigentlich die kämpften eine
bedrohung dar mich nicht also wenig
gewinnt dann sagen die mir doch
jederzeit geschützt vor schweren
verläufen und vor dem tod also ich
konnte ihn aber nicht geschützt vor
einer ansteckung wenn ich geimpft bin
auch drei minuten ins ziel aber gut ich
meine zum beispiel das gesundheitssystem
leben meine was heißt das
gesundheitssystem welches der
krankenhäuser pflegeheime zum beispiel
doch am schluss darum wenn einen kranken
oder voll sind nur wenn ein mensch der
umkämpft ist das ist der die these hier
tablet stelle eine bedrohung dauert für
das kollektiv vor sich wird den neuen
basistarif die zum datenschutz da müssen
wir ehrlich bleiben ziel ist schutz des
gesundheitssystems vor über nazis dem
kenne ich nicht dass ich da machen die
zeiten und zu sagen wir sind ein
umgehend eine bedrohung noch reine
geheimsten kann das auch nicht
warum aber warum haben wir dann keine
grippe impfung ich habe zum beispiel
berichte leben haben 2015 der lagen die
werden sie jetzt einen auf den gängen
die kliniken haben vor überbelegung
gewarnt warum hat damals nicht auch die
politik dann eingegriffen weil das ist
gesundheitssystem tot gespart wird das
wissen wir alle schon seit jahren muss
man da nicht denn auch aufbauen der
getestete ungeimpfte ist im zweifelsfall
gesünder und weniger infektiös als einer
der vor zwei monaten geimpft worden ist
und möglicherweise längst ihren trägt
übrigens ein argument für 2g plus das
kann es ja sein aber für einen jeden
fall meint jedenfalls will gm für jeden
tag getestet damit er arbeiten kann ich
möchte so eine leistung nicht als daher
bei dir für gefährlich halten der
vergleich mit der grippe die einheit die
ich fast an der grenze zum okkultismus
es ist medizinisch nachgewiesen das ist
ein erheblicher unterschied gibt
zwischen einer corona erkrankung und
zwischen einer grippe nicht
doch du hast ist es ähnlich und die mit
dem der krieg ich habe in meinem leben
drei lungenentzündung hab ich habe das
in meinem leben schwerste schwerste
dritten gehabt ich bin nun geschädigt
und ich hatte corona und ich kann dir
gerne mein video vorspielen von meinen
täglichen atemlos anfällen im
krankenhaus ohne sauerstoff nicht einen
schritt weiter riesengroß nicht nein ich
bin kein risikopatient astra ich habe
bronchitis und damit ist man kein risiko
platzieren da sind bitte auch einfach
immer
diesen und sich schlau machen gilt damit
nicht als risiko passieren herz
kreislauf erkrankte oder leute die eine
transplantation hatten also nicht immer
einfach so daher
und da die grippe jetzt noch nach zwei
jahren pandemie die grippe so noch
leichtfertig einfach als
vergleichsmaßstab reinzubringen ich
halte ich für gefährlich weil ich gesagt
das kennen wir ja das argument ja ist
jemand moment ich habe ja noch nicht
gesagt welches das jemand der überhaupt
grippe sagt schon zudem
das hat sie nicht getan
diese reaktion frankenhäuser deutlichen
die berichten damals 215 ich hab nicht
und das möchte ich auch noch meine
kamera sagen ich möchte nicht in keiner
form die grippe mit corona vergleichen
ich wollte nur darauf eingehen weil ja
die belegungen in den krankenhäusern
auch schon in anderen jahren oft
krankenhäuser auf den fluren lagen da
gibt's artikel im netz warum bin ich so
große ereignis kommentieren weiter oder
streifen nicht klappte und wer das
nächste thema präsentieren wir die
grippe sehr freundlich empfangen habt
dann einig dass keiner großes ereignis
heute wampl ja ich stimme ihnen voll zu
wenn man nicht zu sagen hat muss man
auch nichts was war die premiere ich bin
froh dass es stattgefunden hat jetzt
geht das geht so weiter wie es immer war
er noch langweiliger als soll es dieses
vor dieses dieses format weiter geben
und zwar dauerhaft dass der kanzler
wieder die ministerpräsident und die
schließen wieder über die lage und
russland machen wieder alles unter sich
aus warum ist dann dieses gesetz die
pandemische notlage überhaupt jemals
abgeschafft worden wenn es doch so
weiter geht manchem anknüpft an merkel
anna maria scholz knüpft an alte ist ein
neues gesetz was morgen verabschieden
will etwas heißen wird auch wenn keine
epidemischen notlage festgestellt ist
können wir dennoch sehr drakonische
maßnahmen verabschieden das heißt man
ist an einer epidemischen notlage ohne
sie festgesetzt das soll doch der
bundestag tun der kann ja maßnahmen
doch herrn wüst aus